dans le cadre de la donation vollard au
musée léon dierx en 1947 entre au musée
3 céramique de paul gauguin qui sont des
céramiques extrêmement importante dans
l'oeuvre en fête du pain fond c'est
qu'il a il est on ne connaît aucun
peintre où tout le monde a en tête
certains peut-être de ses paysages
tahitien et gauguin est un pas
extrêmement important en fait dans les
années 1880 puisque c'est un peuple qui
qui va s'essayer à faire de la peinture
à faire de la céramique à faire d'une
estampe finalement à faire ce que font
aujourd'hui encore beaucoup d artistes
qui sont un peu d'aidé touche à tout et
dans les années 10 181 il s'essaie à la
haye fait des essais de céramique en
fait il est ici s'exprime avec la la
céramique et donc c'est des céramiques
que dont trois exemplaires en fait sont
arrivés ici au musée léon dierx la pièce
majeure la pièce principale et ce masque
de sauvages quitte en céramique cuite
avec des couleurs qui ont été posées
dessus que gobain gardé quasiment
jusqu'à la fin de service à tahiti qu'il
avait voulu diffuser en forme de masque
en bronze et on connaît au musée d'orsay
une version en bronze de ce masque là et
on il ya une autre version qui se trouve
en plâtre dans une collection privée aux
etats-unis mais la seule et unique
version en terre la plus originale la
plus intéressant ce masque et se trouve
au musée landais à cesser ce masque bon
quitte un peu inquiétant où il a utilisé
la la terre on l'appelle ma ce cheval
certains disent que c'est peut-être
aussi un peu un auto portrait mais en
tout cas c'est quelque chose qu'il a
gardé avec lui
vraiment vraiment toute sa vie pour
pouvoir comme quoi c'était quelque chose
qui auquel il était vraiment attaché
profondément ce masque a une valeur
inestimable d'abord parce que il est
unique
il n'existe qu'en un seul exemplaire il
est construit les il a été fabriqué des
mains de paul gauguin et
et surtout les céramiques de gauguin
régionales sont extrêmement rares et
très collectionner en fait par les
musées mais aussi par les
collectionneurs prévu il ya très très
peu d'exemplaires de céramique et
surtout ses céramiques là c'est vraiment
quelque chose d'important aussi dans
l'histoire de l'art parce que c'est la
naissance de ce qu'on appelle un peu le
primitivisme c'est à dire cette
recherche par les artistes européens
d'autres sources d'inspiration que la
tradition européenne proprement dit qui
est héritée de l'héritage gréco romain
du kaki 6 mai et c'était de la
renaissance et et gauguin est l'un des
premiers justement et après ça va être
le cas de pablo picasso ça va être le
cas d'autres artistes à aller puiser
dans autre chose donc d'autres sources
pour inventer finalement une nouvelle
esthétique invente une nouvelle forme
d'art et ce masque est une une des
étapes 1 d une démarche
justement dans ce processus dans ce
chemin justement vers un renouvellement
complet en fait de l'esthétique en
europe appartient et qui commence dans
les années 80 et qui va triompher avec
les demoiselles d'avignon 1907 par
picasso